The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MARK HARVEY: We have Neil
Leonard with us again.
You all heard the great
concert we had on Wednesday.
So we thought we'd
start out just
by asking if anybody had any
questions or comments based
or that, that you'd like to ask
the performer while he's here.
AUDIENCE: Did it go how
you expected it to go?
NEIL LEONARD: I was
pleased with how it worked.
I didn't really-- I
wasn't really sure
how it would all go.
I kind of had the
basic idea, but there
was a lot of logistical
stuff to do leading up to it.
I was finishing a piece of
the final piece we pay played.
I'd finished that
week, so I just
had my mind full of
details to take care of.
But I was really
pleased at how it went.
And I also was really pleased
because Robin, my collaborator,
was very enthusiastic and
wanted to do it again.
And so, that's kind
of like a goal.
If I do something with
a group of musicians,
to reach the point where people
would want to do it again.
Anybody else?
I think last week I
threatened to make
everybody ask a question.
AUDIENCE: Usually I feel
like a lot of the technology
that people use detracts
from the performance,
but I felt like, definitely,
in this performance
it added a lot of value to
what the audience was hearing.
NEIL LEONARD: How so?
AUDIENCE: It allows
one person to create
so much variety of
sound, and the audience
was able to here all of
the sound at the same time.
When you're just
playing by yourself,
there's only so much you can do.
NEIL LEONARD: I
guess, especially
if you're playing
a wind instrument.
I was reading a biography
of this really famous sax
player, Stan Getz.
And he did a recording in,
I'm guessing in the '70s,
with like a echo kind of box.
Things a tape delay.
An analog tape delay.
And he talked about--
the first recording
he made was published,
it sounds wonderful--.
Have you ever heard that, Mark?
MARK HARVEY: Who's the Guy?
NEIL LEONARD: Stan Getz.
Playing through the echo.
MARK HARVEY: Yes, I have.
NEIL LEONARD: It's
called "Another World,"
or something like that.
He plays wonderfully,
but he also
says that this is a time when,
in the jazz world-- and I think
that in so-called rock
music, electronics
were embraced,
and don't really I
don't remember them
being challenged.
If Pink Floyd , or Jimi Hendrix,
or somebody had synthesizers,
that just seemed like it was OK.
For jazz musicians, it
seemed like it was somehow
straying from this
tradition that
shouldn't be tampered with.
And Stan Getz said that
it felt natural to him.
And it gave him
something to do, which
you couldn't do with the sax.
You play harmony.
So if he played a delay,
he could play one note,
and while that note's ringing,
he could play second note,
and make chords, basically.
Which he'd never been
able to do before.
There's also another
instance from around that era
that caught my attention.
There was a flute
player named Paul Horn.
And he did a recording
at the Taj Mahal.
And I think it was like
this gorilla recording
where he walked in and
set up his tape deck.
Now you probably couldn't take
a tape deck into the Taj Mahal.
I'm guessing.
Or into the Vatican.
You'd be screened.
But he said he pulled the tape
deck out and started to record,
and it was the same thing.
It is a very, very
long reverberation,
so you can build
harmonic structures
for the flute, which you
can't do in a room like this
without the use of electronics.
And so, I don't see a
difference between using the Taj
Mahal to do that, versus
using, like, analog tape delay.
If you get to play chords,
and that's a really fun thing
to play with, then I want to
experiment playing chords.
If I can get the Taj
Mahal, I'm happy to get it
but, I'm not going to bring
the Taj Majal to Killian Hall
downstairs.
Whatever I bring
is probably going
to be some kind of
computer software.
But in principle--
AUDIENCE: I wasn't
saying like-- I just
feel that usually things
don't work as expected.
People will bring in things, and
mics won't work, or whatever.
At the end of the
performance, it
might have been better
if they just played it.
But in this case, things worked
out the way you wanted them to.
NEIL LEONARD: Not
everything worked perfectly.
And I was interested in when
things didn't work perfectly.
It was still a performance,
and if something doesn't work,
you go ahead.
At one point, I put
the wrong page of music
in the music stand, so
when we got to that point,
we missed the first Bar.
But I figured, just go ahead.
Don't worry about.
But I also noticed-- and I don't
know if anybody else caught
this-- but when Robin was
doing the first piece,
he played one piece of
just kind of like delays,
and just like a wah
wah on trombone.
And then he played
a second piece,
that was-- he started
with a drum pad,
and started looping that, and
knowing some of those rhythms,
I knew that if you don't get
the loop right in the drum--.
You can record it with a kind
of a glitch, which he did.
And he didn't
remember how to delete
the last thing he recorded.
So you just see, do I go
ahead with this thing,
which is not really perfect?
And at one point
I could just see,
like, he's just
going to go with it.
And put the rest
of the stuff in,
and start over
dubbing the trombone.
And start playing on top of it.
So I could look back and
think of a handful of things
that, if this is a published
DVD, or published recording,
you would hope you'd
be able to fix somehow.
Or have another take
of, or whatever.
But I think the wonderful
thing about a live performance
is, it's like how do you get
out of the situation you're in?
I've seen sax players,
and their neck strap
breaks during a solo,
and they keep playing.
Or the snare drum breaks
in the middle of a solo,
and the drummer keeps playing.
In a recording, you would stop.
But in a performance,
it sort of like
it was like a basketball
game, or something.
You just can't say, I've
gotta go tie my shoe.
Everybody wait.
You just have to
do it, and that's
a really fascinating kind of
challenge You had a question.
AUDIENCE: What were you
doing in between solos,
when you're going
up to your computer.
Were you changing variables,
or just playing new loops?
NEIL LEONARD:
Between the pieces?
AUDIENCE: No.
NEIL LEONARD: In the piece?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NEIL LEONARD: I'm
trying to remember.
In the first piece I played--.
Depends on the piece.
Sometimes there is
a combination of-- I
would like to be able to
do everything on the fly,
and if I had four hands I
could do everything on the fly.
So I could play the
saxophone, and I
could be in front
of the computer,
and make the computer
do its thing.
So mentally I think
I could do that, too.
I could set it up so
more hands-on involvement
with the computer
would be possible,
but I could still play sax.
But I only have two hands.
And the sax is like the banjo.
Your hands really
have to be there.
You can't really get them
off, and keep playing.
You can't get both of
them off and keep playing.
So some of the music
is created in advance.
So the stuff, which
I think it played
in class last week--
there's a piece I played
that was like time
stretch voice and bells--
we talked about that.
So that is really
kind of a module
of a piece that's composed.
So a lot of time,
it's like working
in Photoshop or something.
You sit there and you
work, and you work,
and you work in sounds.
And you see if they
need any modifications.
You see how to combine them.
You kind of get a sense of the
dramatic flow of the piece.
You work it out.
And then you bring that
file to the concert.
And some of that's playback.
So some of it's play back,
and some of it's live.
Anything that sounded like
process saxophone was live.
But if it sounds like
it was voice, then
that was a vocalist who was
recorded, and then processed,
and then kind of montaged.
So sometimes it was like
triggering the next samples.
I think in the last
piece I played,
I made the software for
that just that week,
if not a couple days before.
That one I think I managed
to mostly do for the panel.
But if it was
getting squirrelly,
I may have gone to
the computer to try
to get it to behave better.
So anything from just
triggering files,
to kind of a small adjustments
to keep it all reined in.
AUDIENCE: So when you
were playing the pieces,
I actually thought that some
of the process saxophone
was recorded.
As I was watching
your foot and seen
when you pressed the pedal.
And it looked like the
pedal did lots of-- I
initially expected the
pedal would be something
simple, like the
pedal adds the delay.
But the pedal caused so
many different effects
that I assumed some of
the saxophone effects
has been pre-recorded and the
pedal was playing them back.
What exactly did you
program the pedal to do?
NEIL LEONARD: The pedal just
sends a signal to the computer.
So it's kind of like a mouse.
It, by itself, is really simple.
You can read the switches
from the computer.
But the way the computer
is set up to respond,
the way I set it up in a concert
to respond to the footwork
work, was fairly
straightforward.
The computer does three
things to the sax.
It will do different
kinds of delays.
And the delays
will-- maybe when we
get through, if you're
still interested,
I could show how the
delay stuff works,
but-- the delay
business works two ways.
One is, it makes an echo.
And the second thing it does, if
you think about the early tape
delays, they have a tape
loop, that just rotated.
The tape loop was
played, and then there
were different playback
heads, to play it back
at different points.
So you have one record
head, and then you
have multiple playback
heads that can be moved.
And if you move,
they kind of echo.
The ricochet kind of effect.
The echo effect changes from
like [MIMING ECHO EFFECT]
You can change those
echoes where there on time.
If you move the
playback head, it's
also a changing the speed
that its reading the tape.
So if you have a note which
is [MAKES NOTE SOUND].
And the tape is going like this.
And you move the
playback head this way,
you're going to get
glissando [MAKES NOTE SOUND]
Because you're increasing the
speed at which the tape is
passing over the playback head.
If you move it the
other way, it goes down.
So in the digital world,
you can get that, too.
So, the delays are kind of
modeling a tape delay system.
You can speed up, while you're
sort of moving the playback
heads, you get
pitch consequences.
Or kind of result in glassindos,
or glassindi, as well.
The other, third
thing which makes
the delay business
complicated, is there's
a foot pedal which--
not everything's
going to delay-- which
changes things radically.
So if you play a phrase,
and at the end of the phrase
you feed more of
that into the delay,
it kind of accentuates
that one thing.
Sort of like a sustained
pedal on a piano.
If you put it down for
half of the phrase,
but not the rest of the
phrase, one part of the phrase
has this accentuation, or this
effect, that the rest of it
doesn't have.
And that can be a
tremendous, dramatic change.
But to keep it short,
there's a delay.
There is kind of like
a pitch bend idea.
There is a flute player
you guys might have heard,
a gun named Robert Dick,
who made a glissando
head for the flute.
And the way it works is,
it slides in and out.
So you play a note, and
there's a thumb thing.
And use this thumb thing,
lever, whatever it is,
to make this head joint slide.
So I think that the blow
hole's not changing,
but I think something on
this side of the head joint
is changing.
So the glissando flute.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEIL LEONARD: Is it the
mouth piece that slides?
I've never actually seen one.
OK.
So I wanted to do that
with the saxophone,
but I resorted to doing
it electronically.
I wanted, like if
there was a harmonizer,
there are three voices
playing in harmony.
I wanted those three
pages all to be variable,
so they could
slide in real time.
And I had particular ways in
which I like to slide them.
But sometimes you
heard a harmony,
and it sounded like
there was a whammy
bar, or sort of a glissando.
I built like a harmonizer with
a glissando mechanism in it.
And so, the second one.
And the third one
is really simple.
I don't use it as much.
Actually, there's four
things I've been doing.
The third one was just
a random looping thing.
It's like so the
random cut and paste.
So I'd play something
into the computer,
and it takes snippets of
that, and kind of like
feeds them back, or
replays them in sort
of an arbitrary
fashion a real time.
So it doesn't sound like a
beat-oriented looping effect.
It's just sending
back fragments of what
you played in a kind
of unpredictable way.
So you get a kind of a
stochastic re-compositon,
or re-improvisiation of
something you played.
That was the third thing.
AUDIENCE: The final
one, I just figured out
a couple days for the concert,
was a kind of freeze effect.
It's using anybody's intel,
like audio engineering.
It's using fast Fourier
transforms, which basically
take a snapshot of
the sound, in terms
of the pitches that
are in the sound.
Remember when we looked at that
piece of software last week?
We took, I think
a trombone sample,
I think that's what we had.
And then we were stretching
, and we were cutting it up,
and playing with it.
So for software like that, you
can take a so-called frame,
we'll say it's a
24th of a second,
and do a spectral analysis
of that 24th of a second.
And then freeze it.
Just play those frequencies
in the frequency domain,
and just hold it.
And so I have, I think
eight of those going.
And every time I
hit a peddle, you
freeze another instance in time.
So the idea was twofold.
One was to, again, to
build up harmonies.
So every time I had a not
that I wanted to freeze,
I'd hit the peddle, and
that gets sustained.
But then there was kind
of a poetic idea, which
is really sort of pun in a way.
But the song I
playing was playing
is a song called,
"Round Midnight."
It's very slow, and
very kind of somber.
And I thought this idea
also fit with that song,
because it's like stillness.
The song is quiet,
slow, still, and this
would make it extremely still,
because it freezes things.
So I played around a
little bit with that.
So those were the things that
you could do with the sax.
It's actually quite
a bit of stuff.
And when you think of it, when
you think of what guitarists
like Jimi Hendrix used, he
didn't have that much stuff.
He had like fuzz box,
he had wah wah pedal.
And maybe like one more thing.
I'm not a guitar
effects connoisseur.
There isn't a lot of stuff,
but it changes the guitar
completely.
So I'm finding
that I, too, don't
need lots and lots of stuff.
In fact, the fewer things you
have to use to process the sax,
the easier it is, because
there's not that many choices.
So you still think
you're playing
the sax, with a few, fairly
straight forward things
you can vary.
So that's sort of,
I think for Robin
and myself, soft
of the inspiration.
We found guitar players
modifying the guitar,
we think, well, why can't
we do that, as well?
So, we can.
We can do it without an
extensive background.
Robin does not have an extensive
music technology background--
or with a different,
more evolved background
in music technology,
which I have.
And both of them will work.
In the case of Robin, he's
such a good trombonist,
and improviser, that you
give me a couple things,
and he does great stuff with it.
Those were some of the
things I was playing around
with, or using the computer to
do, to extend the performance.
MARK HARVEY: Let me shift so
we can get our projects in,
and if people have
questions at the end,
we will hopefully
have time for that.
So we have our teams again.
And so, what I think
we should do is,
Neil will help with
logistics, if you
want to set up a computer,
or whatever you have.
So we should just go.
And the team should
just say a little bit
about what it is your idea
is, and then enact it.
So who would like to go first?
AUDIENCE: So me and Brian,
we both recorded sounds
separately.
I recorded sounds in
my kitchen, and made it
sort of like a
sound stage thing.
And then, Brian recorded
some guitar sounds,
and other sounds he found
[? at the bakery ?],
and he put on them on this
little mini board, which
you can play different
sounds and stuff.
So I'm using Ableton
Live [INAUDIBLE]
MARK HARVEY: Did you come up
with a design, or a framework,
or is it just going to
be sort of spontaneous?
AUDIENCE: The framework
is the kitchen sounds
kind of form a beat, and we're
going to be going around that.
[MUSIC SOUNDS] I recorded
most of the sounds here.
We'll just go into
some of the sounds.
One was my lamp
switching on and off.
Another is my
guitar feeding back.
Another is an
effects pedal that I
have that does some
really wacky pitch shifts
and dive bombs, essentially.
And mine, I was banging
on random things.
And then I used a
harpoon growler as a jug.
And some other things.
I forgot everything.
Bottle caps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL LEONARD: That was cool.
It sounded like a
voice, that last thing.
AUDIENCE: Yes, that
actually was my voice.
NEIL LEONARD: You've
got new careers.
Very coo.
AUDIENCE: So we recorded
sounds just on an iPad.
And then, put them on there.
And we're just
playing everything.
About eight different tracks,
[INAUDIBLE], no data tape.
And we're just going to be
looping those all the time,
on different tracks, on and off.
And then, I'm going to briefly
play the piano, at the start.
And then just come
and control this.
MARK HARVEY: What
are the sounds?
AUDIENCE: Right.
It's sort of more
ambiance, rather than
snippets of sound bites.
It's sorta like
longer recordings.
It's like a shower.
MARK HARVEY: OK.
Shower type of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You can figure
out what sort of--
MARK HARVEY: So
it's a challenge.
We've got to figure out
what the sounds are.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Did you have that
ending worked out?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
That was actually a
recording of a door creaking,
that had some pitch to it.
So we decided to use that.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARK HARVEY: Very interesting.
Very interesting.
Let's give a round of
applause, first of all.
AUDIENCE: I think a
lot of the other groups
had some mixed background noise
that they recorded, and then
improvised with their
instruments on top of that.
And I was feeling a
little sick, and didn't
want to play my
trumpet, so I took
sort of complimentary approach.
The sounds I recorded
will be the improvisation.
So I went around my dorm and
recorded 15 different sounds.
And then wrote a Python
script that sort of generates
a random way to
play these sounds.
So at different sections of the
song, like at the beginning,
it only picks from
a certain number
of these sounds, all of
which sound like fans.
At the beginning, it's
like a fan and AC,
a few other things like that.
And then as it progresses, it
adds on more of these sounds.
I have a little solo
section in the middle.
We'll even hear a couple
of appliances, and noises.
Big solos, and then it
goes out to some ending.
So the direction of
the piece is planned,
but exactly what sound
is played, and when,
and for how long,
all that is randomly
generated each time we play it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK HARVEY: So
it's your program
that's doing the improvising?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARK HARVEY: Very interesting.
AUDIENCE: So to answer the
other question, what it will do
is, it will play a sound,
play random sounds,
wait for a random
amount of time,
and then play another sound.
Sometimes it waits until
the sound is finished,
sometimes it doesn't.
So that it can be positive,
that can be restive,
and there can also
be two or three
sounds playing at the same time.
The only thing, I put the solos
so there was never two solos
playing at the same time.
And I made sure that each
solo was played once.
But otherwise, all
the other sounds,
you have multiple [INAUDIBLE].
Yes I had the dishwasher sounds
not play until the very end.
And I closed the
dishwasher a few times
until I got a nice satisfying
crash and recorded that.
MARK HARVEY: Did
you break anything?
OK next contestants.
AUDIENCE: We
recorded five sounds.
A door closing, someone typing
on the keyboard, a pencil
scratching, a zipper, and
a microwave turning on.
I assigned them to different
keys on the keyboard, here.
So I'm going to make a
beat with these noises,
with these sounds,
while they improvise.
MARK HARVEY: Did you say a beat?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I'm using them
mostly as percussion.
So the sounds were things
that I [INAUDIBLE] homework,
so I guess that is our theme.
MARK HARVEY: Homework?
AUDIENCE: Like you got
the drone or a beat
or just melody or
some [INAUDIBLE]
Whatever you want to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING
[APPLAUSE]
MARK HARVEY: So given that's
a sort of existential homework
moment, what time
of the day or night
would you project
that to be happening?
AUDIENCE: After I just ate.
MARK HARVEY: After you just ate.
Very cool.
OK.
Another group.
AUDIENCE: Each of us
had a different idea
that was discussed
in class last time.
I think we tried all the
ideas, and none of them
really worked, because we didn't
have good enough recording
equipment, and we
weren't good enough
at using that recording
equipment to effectively do
anything.
So we decided on a--
[INAUDIBLE] So you
might recognize some
of these Sounds.
We found a sound
board on the internet.
Unfortunately it's
mono-phonic, so the amount
of stuff we could do is
a little bit limited.
We were planning on
using this sound [PING]
as a sort of reset button
for between the sections.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK HARVEY: Good.
Good.
That the idea.
AUDIENCE: I don't
feel so guilty saying
that at times I was
trying to make you
guys feel uncomfortable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MARK HARVEY: Thanks
for the extra effort.
That was actually fascinating
to watch you do all that stuff.
Neil, do you want to
just make a few comments,
or whatever you want to do.
NEIL LEONARD: How many people
have done something like this
before?
Anybody?
And suddenly you've
done Ableton Live.
And how many people
have done Ableton Live?
One, two.
So, what have you done
with Ableton Live before?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Just
learning how to use it.
I really haven't
been that into it,
because I feel very limited,
because I haven't actually
bought the full version.
NEIL LEONARD: So you're
starting to use it now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NEIL LEONARD: OK.
Just curious.
AUDIENCE: In the
past, though, I worked
with Serato Scratch
Live, though.
Actually, I use that for DJ'ing.
NEIL LEONARD: OK.
Yes, but in terms
of-- when I asked
the question of how many
of you have done something
like this live, what
I'm wondering about
is how many people have
recorded sounds on their own,
and used them in a
musical performance?
You have?
For composition.
OK.
And performance is a
little bit different,
but it's a little bit
the same, as well.
It is really interesting to
hear what you guys came up with,
not knowing you very well.
With my Berkeley
students, I always
feel like, when they bring
in their assignments,
it sounds so much like them.
But I have a longer
time to work with them.
So I can make some
more connections.
One of the things that came
up in watching you perform,
is where is the value
in doing something
you haven't done before, or
something that you may not
be comfortable with?
As a sort of
experimental adventure.
And when I listen to Sarah,
and Ben's and James's piece,
one of the things which
seems to be interesting,
is that you guys didn't really
know where it was going to go.
You didn't know where
it was going to end.
You said, that's not
quite what we rehearsed.
And that can be a
really wonderful thing.
Because the opposite is-- when
I played the concert that you
saw, if it happened
exactly the way
it happened a time before,
or happened every time,
you run the risk
of the spark dying.
So the excitement of
the performance-- kind
of like rigor mortis sets in.
The spontaneity goes
away, and the spark.
The excitement for
the performer can
be linked to the spontaneity.
And you lose the excitement
for the performer,
and the spontaneity.
So when you guys
were playing didn't
know where it was going
to go, I thought, well,
that's actually a good
thing to just bring up.
Because that's the
desired effect.
And it's a struggle
for the improviser, who
plays for decades, to keep
the thing feeling fresh.
I know for me, there
are things you can do.
I guess it's like when
you're performing,
and you're distracted, or
you're just not really--.
What I'm getting at is,
for me the performances
are the least satisfying when
one of two thing happens.
Either I can't relax,
and get in the play.
So if it's a concert,
like with Robin,
for example, if I feel for
any reason uncomfortable,
if the challenge of it
kinda psych's me out,
or I don't think I know
the music well enough,
and I start to play,
and all of a sudden you
feel that tension, that anxiety
of trying to get to the music.
It's not like a stage fright,
it's not like a performance
anxiety, but you feel
like you're forcing it.
And once you feel like
you're forcing it,
in a performance of
improvised music,
you begin to lose a
little bit of control.
And then the other
thing is if I feel like,
oh I just played what
I played yesterday.
I did what I knew
I could do easily.
Then you don't
discover anything new.
And I think that what's kind
of fundamental in improvisation
is this feeling that you're
discovering something new.
Even if small things
are new, but you
keeping that little bit
of the activity alive.
Doing something which is
not necessarily comfortable
or not something
you've done before
can sometimes turn
into a big gain.
The other things I was
thinking about with that piece
are-- At first I was
thinking I wanted everybody
to record yourself.
And then you guys,
Sarah, James, and Ben,
at first I was a
little bit concerned,
because you just grabbed some
sounds from the computer, which
I told you not to do.
But the thing which I
thought worked really well
is, we have such a visceral
connection to those sounds.
They have a tremendous
meaning for us.
They give us knee
jerk responses,
Like if my cell phone is
in inadvertently right now.
And I hear a text message sound,
all of a sudden I kind of jump.
My body reacts like I
have to do something.
So those sounds have a
tremendous kind of power.
And we have very
important associations,
strong associations,
with those sounds.
So they're totally loaded, and
the way you played with them,
I thought was
really, really fun.
I think that the
Windows operating system
is more musical than the Mac.
Side note.
I'm just putting out
some ideas that I
was thinking about
listening to everybody play.
The other thing
I was thinking of
is-- and this is also very
true in Austin's piece--
is that working with computers.
Computers are not
nearly as responsive
as a flute, a
violin, as a trumpet.
You're making music
with your index finger.
You're not using your whole arm.
You're not using your mouth.
You're not using your breathing.
You're not even
using your hands.
Are using your index finger.
You're moving and clicking.
But I'm also in my
own work, interested
in the resistance
of the materials.
So, the computer
is totally limited.
Or this assignment I gave you.
Make a performance, it's going
to be three minutes long.
You only have a week to make it.
You're going to record
sounds in your own.
Right there it limits what
you can do quite a bit.
But when an artist is
presented with limitations,
it's amazing to see what
artists come up with.
So the resistance
of the materials
takes you someplace new.
So for example, I'm
reviewing a piece of music
which is very difficult
to improvise on.
A very complicated
set of chord changes.
I tried the other day.
I'm just going to play
with my left hand.
The metronome was fast,
the harmonic progressions
really hard.
I'm playing the same
thing over and over again.
I'm finding my rut.
So what if I just play
with my left hand?
And I tried that for while.
And all of a sudden, I felt
like I'm getting out of my rut,
because I had to think
about it differently.
I had to find new things
that I could do this hand.
Put them both back
into play again,
and it feels like it's fresh.
So the idea of doing this
very short exercise that
uses this kind of rigid,
somewhat unresponsive tool,
to make music, has
historically produced
some really interesting
things that we haven't got out
of the previous
concert music practice.
So those are just some of
things I was thinking about.
I think if we were
to do this again--
if this was a four unit
class, of if this was Berkeley
and you were doing this
as your thesis project--
I think the kind of challenges
I found in the last two pieces
would be very interesting
to continue to explore.
So what about when you've
overextended yourself.
And you're playing some
piano, and some violin,
and some computer.
Or in my case-- you heard
me in Killian hall--
I'm doing delay effects, and
I'm playing back samples,
and I'm playing saxophone.
And I'm beginning to
overextend myself.
It's an interesting
problem, and the solutions
you found-- it was wonderful
to watch you trying
to grapple with that
problem, and come up
with some very
interesting solutions.
And I am also very
keen on this idea of,
is there a set of
sounds that you
can find that have a
really special quality?
When you hear Glenn Gould
play the Goldberg variations
on piano-- and the aria
of the Goldberg variations
is a very, very simple piece--
and he just sounds phenomenal.
He's playing quarter notes.
It's just mind boggling
good, and he has barely
even started the piece.
This is amazing.
It's the way he plays.
But I guess that's the next
question I have for you guys.
Are there particular
sounds that you
hear that would be a
good start to a piece?
That just have that kind
of mesmerizing effect.
And they're not
necessarily music.
I think with the Windows
operating system piece,
you also had the
advantage of some
of those micro compositions.
Like [MAKES NOTE SOUNDS].
Whatever that is.
That's like the shut down
sound, or the boot up sound,
or something.
Like there are already kind
of audio jingles, which
have been very, very
carefully created.
And we've heard them many times.
They have tremendous
meaning for us.
But are there sounds that you
hear in the world around you,
that would make a really
good beginning of a piece.
Let's just forget the
whole piece for now.
Let's just say the
beginning of the piece.
Something that would
be fantastic to hear
at the beginning.
That would be an
interesting thing to pursue.
I'm trying to remember the
other solo artist in this group.
Jacob, right?
Jacob, where I would like
to see that work go is,
is there a way that you
can share the improvisation
with the computer?
So you created a
piece of software
that basically automates an
idea about improvisation.
You have an idea of how
the sounds could play.
Sometimes they play
together, Sometimes
there's silence between them.
Sometimes there's 3 over 1.
Sometimes they're dove
tailing were overlapping.
Sometimes they're not.
Is there a way to
extend that so you
are a physical participant
in the improvisation,
and the computer is
playing a disembodied you.
Because basically
what it's doing now
is like a disembodied you.
It's your idea implemented
as a program that
will execute your idea.
Is there a way to
have two of you?
The virtual you, which is what
we heard, and the you present.
So, I'm a teacher, so
I'm always thinking
for my own students,
what do I do
to get everybody
to the next step?
Because we're never done.
I study all the time.
I try to learn new stuff.
I could tell you all about that.
We don't have the time.
But I'm always thinking for
you guys, what's the next step?
And I think that
for Jacob's work,
that would be a next step.
I'll just try to
touch on one more.
Alex, Chelsea, and Chris's,
the homework theme.
I guess, if you hadn't
told me it was homework.
I might have been able to
distinguish it from the others.
But I love the idea of homework.
And what moment
of homework would
be really great to zero in on.
It's so rich.
Is it like procrastination?
The feeling that you
learned something new?
The anxiety of, oh, no
I've got Neil's assignment,
it's due in and hour
and I haven't started.
There's all kinds of ways
to think about homework.
And it's such a central
part of your lives.
What could you do to
take that another step?
I think it's a great theme.
And what could you
do to distinguish it
from all the other
works we heard?
So I think that, in short,
all these pieces are really
wonderful beginnings.
And I don't think any
of these beginnings
is more or less
valuable than any other.
But I guess my bias
is thinking, if we
were to continue this,
what would be a next step
to engage in.
To take the same ideas and
develop them a little bit more?
MARK HARVEY: Great
thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
NEIL LEONARD: Thank you.
It was great to hear your work,
and good to talk to you guys
about it.
MARK HARVEY: Great
job everybody.
Very interesting The
only things I would add
is that I was interested how
much the percussive element
came out in a lot
of people's pieces.
Percussive sounds, the
way you've arranged them,
and also how the live
instrumentals played with that.
And actually, very
little silence.
There were a couple pieces that
had more silence than others,
but interesting to
think about that.
So again, more things
to keep in mind.
NEIL LEONARD: The Windows
piece had great silence.
MARK HARVEY: Yeah
NEIL LEONARD: And I
think the performers
are kept on edge with that.
MARK HARVEY: It kept
the audience on.
I didn't know what was going on.
OK, so please send in
just a little statement
about what this was,
this project today.
And your concert reflection
on Neil's concert.
And we'll see you Wednesday for
something completely different.
Thank you, thank you.